[موسيقى]
نحن لدينا فريضه الصيام هناك نوعان من
الصيام الاول
ثلاثه ايام واليوم الرابع يكون العيد
وصيام عيد اقوال تاسست وهذا عاده ما يكون
في اربعينيه الشتاء وهو ايضا صيام
لثلاثه ايام ويكون العيد في اليوم الرابع
كذلك نحن نؤدي فريضه الصلاه وهي صلاه
الفجر وصلاه المغرب ومثل الاديان الاخرى
فالانسان في حاجه الى التواصل مع الله
وذلك يتم عن طريق الصلاه وعند صلاه الفجر
نتوجه نحو شروق الشمس وفي صلاه المغرب
نتوجه نحو الشمس عنده هروبها وفي كلتا
الصلاتين نترجى رحمه الله اما لماذا نتوجه
نحو الشمس
[موسيقى]
الكاكائيون او دين اليرسان بشكل عام تشكل
الموسيقى عندهم اهميه كبيره وهي مقدسه
لديهم لانهم يعتقدون انها صوت الحقيقي
[موسيقى]